>> Laura: FACEBOOK'S TREATMENT
OF DIAMOND & SILK IS JUST THE
LATEST EXAMPLE OF CENSORING
CONSERVATIVE VOICES.
THE PRO-TRUMP SISTERS BECAME A
HOT TOPIC.
FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG
SECOND DAY OF GRILLING ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
>> DO YOU SUBJECTIVELY
MANIPULATE YOUR ALGORITHMS TO
PRIORITIZE OR CENSOR SPEECH?
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, WE DON'T THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE DOING AS
CENSORING SPEECH.
THERE ARE TYPES OF CONTENT LIKE
TERRORISM THAT I THINK WE ALL
AGREE WE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE ON
OUR SERVICE.
SO WE BUILD SYSTEMS THAT CAN
IDENTIFY THOSE AND CAN REMOVE
THAT CONTENT, AND WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF THAT WORK.
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING
RIGHT NOW.
DIAMOND & SILK IS NOT TERRORISM.
>> Laura: ZING.
LET'S GET REACTION FROM THE
LADIES THEMSELVES.
MARSHA BLACKBURN JUMPED ON IT
BECAUSE MARK ZUCKERBERG WAS
LIKE, WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
TERRORISM.
I DON'T SEE ANY TERRORISM, I
DON'T SEE ANY THREAT TO
COMMUNITY STANDARDS OR WHATEVER
THE HECK THEIR JUSTIFICATION IS.
I DON'T SEE ANY OF IT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PLAY YOU'VE GOT AT THE HEARING
AND DID YOU GET ANY SATISFACTION
FROM WHAT MARK ZUCKERBERG SAID?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE THAT REALLY
STOOD UP FOR US AND OUR
PLATFORM.
EVEN OTHER CONSERVATIVES.
WITH MARK ZUCKERBERG, I WAS
HAPPY TO HEAR HIM ADMIT THEY
MADE A MISTAKE.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR HIM TO RECTIFY
THAT MISTAKE.
I WOULD LIKE, WE WOULD LIKE TO
SIT DOWN AND TALK DIRECTLY TO
MARK ZUCKERBERG SO THAT HE CAN